el ataque de esta mañana en bagdad se
llevó a cabo en una de las plazoletas
más céntricas y más concurridas de la
ciudad con un gran bazar que suele ser
bastante visitado especialmente en horas
de las mañanas las autoridades hablan de
dos hombres suicidas con cinturones
llenos de explosivos que habrían
realizado el ataque el primero se habría
hecho el enfermo lo que hizo que varias
personas se acercaran a ayudarlo en ese
momento se explotó luego vinieron otros
a ayudar a los heridos lo que hizo que
el segundo se explotara nuevamente lo
que hizo que este atentado tuviera esta
gran magnitud las defensas civiles los
militares hablan de 28 muertos y 70
heridos pero se cree que la cifra puede
aumentar en las próximas horas el último
gran atentado que había visto bagdad
había sido en este mismo lugar en enero
de 2018 cuando ya se había declarado la
victoria contra el llamado estado
islámico o isis que todavía tiene
células en el país que han venido
haciendo ataques en algunos lugares muy
concretos no en la capital y aunque
ellos no se han reclamado la autoría
todas las miradas van hacia ellos